soeben wurde das urteil verkündete unser
bild reporter jörg völkerling ist jetzt
im landesgericht salzburg ag ist das
urteil ausgefallen
ja wir stehen in diesem moment vor dem
saal und hinter mir berät sich der
angeklagte gottfried wo gerade mit
seinem anwalt über dieses urteil der
richter philip großer hat ihn zu
lebenslanger freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
seine einweisung in eine anstalt für
geistig abnorme rechtsbrecher und hat
den hinterbliebenen von helga b und
ingrid b auch noch ein schmerzensgeld
von über 90.000 euro zugesprochen er hat
gesagt strafmildernd sei zwar dass
straffreie vorleben und seine abnormale
persönlichkeitsstruktur erschwerend
kommt aber hinzu es sind zwei frauen
gestorben es ist diese unübliche
überschießende einsatz von gewalt der
hier zum tragen gekommen sei und darüber
hinaus hat der richter auch noch die
einziehung der beiden waffen von
gottfried
angeordnet im moment sehen wir wie
gesagt andreas schweitzer der
verteidiger berät mit ihm ob man dieses
urteil gleich annehmen soll es war ja
das ziel verteidigung eine zeitige
freiheitsstrafe 20 jahre zu erreichen
dieses ziel hat der verteidiger jetzt
nicht erreicht allerdings bedeutet eine
lebenslange freiheitsstrafe in
österreich auch nicht wirklich
lebenslang sondern 25 jahre es kann aber
auch viel viel mehr seien letztlich denn
ein psychiater psychologen der ihn
behandelt in dieser anstalt muss
regelmäßig ein gutachten erstatten ob
seine sadistische
sadistisch narzistische persönlichkeit
struktur geheilt ist und ob er wirklich
keine gefahr für die allgemeinheit mehr
darstellt dass also die reaktion des
angeklagten und seinem anwalt gibt es
denn auch schon eine reaktion aus der
opferfamilie
ja ich habe tatsächlich mit einem
verwandten ein cousin von stefan boss
auch gesprochen die hier diesen prozess
verfolgt haben und ihnen ging es vor
allen dingen darum dass ich auch mal
aufgeklärt wird wie lachs die
waffengesetze sind wie vielleicht eine
so psychisch auffällige figur wie
gottfried doch an waffen kommt und als
privatdetektiv arbeiten konnte
der bruder roberto hat ja robert b hat
ja in der verhandlung immer wieder auch
thematisiert dass die polizei ihn nicht
wirklich geholfen habe er sagt bei
seiner anzeigeerstattung fünf monate vor
der tat hätten das gefühl gehabt die
duzen sich alle mit gottfried und man
heutigen gesagt ja wenn der wieder vor
der tür steht dann ruft den notruf an
und er hat dann gesagt ja dann kommt sie
hierher zum laichen zählen sowie in
kitzbühel wo kurz zuvor ein mann fünf
leute erschossen hatte also dass und
gottfried ist eine so auffällige
persönlichkeit der schon den 90er jahren
offenbar seiner ex lebenspartnerin sehr
gefährliche situation beschert hat sehr
jähzornig war im straßenverkehr unfälle
herbeigeführt hat ihr ein paar ihren
wellensittich gequält hat das hat alles
aber nicht dazu geführt dass gottfried
irgendwann mal verurteilt wurden wäre es
ja vollkommen unbelastet straff ohne
strafe strafen in dieses verfahren
gekommen und hat aber angekündigt dass
er sich seiner verurteilung mit seiner
strafe jetzt stellen will und hofft dass
die therapie ihm hilft seine
persönlichkeit zu ändern und zu bessern
vielen dank jörg völkerling diese ganz
aktuellen eindrücke vom urteil im
landesgericht salzburg
[Musik]